let's get cooking guys oh that's too
much sauce
i'm whisking look at that peel i feel
like i made a few mistakes here oh
accident a little butt wrapped in them
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okaiest
mom and thanksgiving
is almost here well by the time you're
watching this thanksgiving will be over
but
whatever it is going to be quite the
unconventional one so i figure why not
have an unconventional meal so this
thanksgiving i'm gonna let the boys
meal plan our thanksgiving feast and
cook it start to finish let's hope we
don't have to order a pizza for
thanksgiving dinner but
we'll see wish us luck
[Music]
so the rules of this thanksgiving feast
are
there are no rules the boys can pick
whatever they want to eat
and i will figure it out and help them
cook it
what i want to focus on is them cooking
as much as possible because
i want them to learn and i want them to
feel like
they accomplish something with this
feast i draw the line at sharp knives
and open flame and like really hot food
out of the oven
so i'll be taking over those tasks when
we're planning the menu i will
nudge them in the direction of having a
more complete meal but honestly
if they want to have all dessert we can
have all dessert it's thanksgiving it's
time to stuff your face
let's go tell the boys so you know how
thanksgiving is gonna be a little
different this year
yeah well i thought we could have fun
with it and
dad and i will let you guys choose the
menu and what we eat
for thanksgiving yay
and you know what else you guys are
gonna cook it too yeah i'm gonna use the
oven
and burn myself oh my god the first step
was sitting down with the boys and
coming up with a menu for the evening
we usually have like turkey stuffing
mashed potatoes
green beans pie
i know rice crispy turkey what is a rice
krispie turkey
it's a turkey made out of recipes
a turkey made out of rice krispie treat
yeah
wyatt does that sound good to you i hope
they don't pick
ribs because it's a lot of work for me
and it's a real pain to time all the
food with the ribs in the smoker
please don't choose ribs please don't
choose ribs please don't choose ribs
[Music]
they chose ribs banana bread banana
bread yeah
okay uh no stuffing stuffing
made out of banana bread stuffing made
out of banana bread
yeah i don't think i've ever even heard
of that
okay what about like a veggie
broccoli broccoli okay how do you want
me to make the broccoli
broccoli with chocolate chocolate
covered broccoli
i'm not doing that mama and purple
mashed potatoes
purple mashed potatoes yeah purple and
chicken eggs chicken legs
you're a meat eater huh i think we have
a nice list
menu was set i ordered the groceries and
it was time to start prepping the food
all right it is the day before our feast
and we have some food that we need to
prep
tonight we're gonna make the banana
bread because if we are
making stuffing out of it it needs to be
dried out you guys are taking the lead
on this banana bread okay
yeah and i'm here if you need help okay
i got a fork
mash them up
[Music]
i always say that cooking is therapy and
that's exactly why look at all the anger
you can take out
on something that isn't going to get
hurt r.i.p bananas
can i show you a trick you don't stab
the banana you mash it against the sides
this looks about right crack two eggs
get it yeah okay we're gonna add some
vanilla extract
two cups cinnamon go ahead and put the
baking soda in all of this and then i'll
mix it
i just eyeball it oh that's too much
salt
and we need a cup of sugar jackson go
ahead and start gently stirring
we can do it lovely how do you feel
about it wyatt
good
let's get this in the oven guys i'm
going to prep the ribs okay that's good
that's good
rib prep is gross and my kids are not at
that stage where i can trust them to
touch rami or even have gloves on and
touch raw meat and not touch other
surfaces in the kitchen or their faces
so i took on the ribbon chicken press
dude
while i was doing the meat prep the boys
were
watching tv typical i coat it in a dry
brine
i love me some butt rub no one else
appreciates the butt rub the way that i
do in our house
and i dry brine it overnight in the
fridge so that it gets
really really flavorful and then i smoke
them all day long
i just heard the banana bread is done
hey boys
whoo baby hot hot this
looks delish
so our whole house smells amazing we
have
cubed this and i'm going to lightly
cover it and let it just
really dry out try it
it's so good prep day was done the
chicken and ribs were seasoned
the banana bread was drying and we were
all set to
have a whole other day of cooking all
right it is the day
of the thanksgiving feast
henry's feasting you having lunch
so the overall plan was for me to take
all of the tasks that go over an open
flame
and put things in and out of the oven
obviously that didn't even remotely
happen
so we're getting a late start i have
some water
pouring in here to boil the potatoes get
get that football out of here
go wash your hands we have rice crispy
treats getting started
we have purple potatoes boiling
wyatt is handling the banana red pudding
mixture with the milk and the eggs and
all of that
and then jackson is going to prep the
broccoli
casserole the ribs are on the smoker
they have six hours
and then for the appetizer grape or
olives
i love favorites matt's family has a
business it's an olive business they're
called grape or olives
you might see them in your grocery store
they're pretty expensive olives but
they're
so good oh you need some vanilla extract
a little bit okay okay now good
all right yup go ahead and pour the milk
in
the milk right here
oh okay
can i whisk yeah go ahead and whisk very
carefully
hold the bowl with your arm i use it
oh look at that peel peek of the
rice krispie treat mixture wow plan for
the rice crispy turkey was just to make
a
huge batch of rice krispie treat mixture
and once the mixture is a little cool
and easier to mold we would all
collectively try to mold it into a
turkey shape
if we pull this off this will be the
most
genius idea ever so we
had gloves on to mold the rice krispies
turkey they did not fit wyatt's hands
because we still have i'm single oh my
goodness you're missing a finger no he
was more of a taste tester
than an actual help
else you want to do something else
unfold in useless shapes
why because it's fun it was
super cute it looked a lot like a turkey
and we did a really good job
i say we because there was a lot of help
from me all right wyatt
move on to the stuffing so you're gonna
put all those cubes in the dish
this is gonna take 51 hours exactly
why decently okay at helping out in the
kitchen but it's definitely not his
specialty
so a really good quiet task is taking
something and putting it in another
container
jackson can you place your banana slices
on top
scatter them all around let's pour this
over first cause it has to soak for
about five minutes
we're gonna sprinkle chocolate chips and
walnuts
so i cut a little slit in my potatoes
before i boil them
because they are so easy to peel
in typical kid fashion we did not come
out of this day without an accident
it is time to do the broccoli
casserole so can you get that cream of
mushroom soup in there
i'm going to improvise a little here
we're going to add a little heavy cream
so i feel like that's good
then we need to shred some cheddar
can i swear do you know how
can i do i'm really nervous so you're
gonna hold it
like this i know hold it like that and
then you take the cheese
yeah i know how to do that and you
either do it like that or you can do it
like this
and it's hard to do so do you want me to
hold this for you
yeah okay that's the wrong direction
no no no you go down not up yeah
they go one direction it's one yeah yeah
jackson take a turn and then why take
another turn okay
okay go ahead like this
yep okay
there you go
did you cut your finger okay okay wait
leave it leave it leave it
leave it honey come here hold on oh
accident so when jackson went to grate
his cheese he pushed
way too hard and the grater flipped
out and he ended up grading his knuckle
which if you've ever done before i can
attest to it i've done it to myself
multiple times it really hurts
jackson was such a trooper he was so
brave and he just wanted
a band-aid and to move on with his day
oh wow that looks so realistic
the best task to delegate to kids truly
is like
decorating and frosting jackson how's
your finger
is it okay yes rice krispie turkey was
done and it was time to sit down and eat
here we are i thought we came up with an
amazing feast i thought it was really
creative
but everything still looked really
delicious and it's
not something that strayed too far from
a thanksgiving dinner
what's your favorite part chicken
how are the potatoes the potatoes my
favorite
really jax's favorite dish was the
potatoes which is really interesting for
him because he's usually not a huge
mashed potato guy i think the purple
color sweetened the deal and made them
look really fun
and exciting and like something new when
i just prepared him
the way i typically make mashed potatoes
i have never
seen him more happy to eat a meal henry
loved the chicken he doesn't eat a lot
of meat either it's so
fun experiencing this with him because
he's trying all these new foods and he's
just getting started
and so every time he tries something new
that he loves he does this little dance
with his arms to get more food
and it was so cute to watch
[Applause]
and then when it was time to eat the
turkey i decided that i was going to
carve it
like a traditional turkey
it looks so realistic
it's so good after it was all said and
done the boys really didn't cook
thanksgiving dinner
they advised on what to make and i ended
up cooking it this year was a difficult
year
not only for my family but for the
entire world
nobody's keeping it together right now
honestly what we've experienced has been
a sliver of the hardship that a lot of
other people have had to live through
and if you're watching this i hope that
this holiday you get to see your family
i hope you're safe and well
if you don't get to see your family then
you get to be a part of my family
and you got to join our thanksgiving
so thank you for coming and now here is
a clip of wyatt
dancing after the meal it just embodies
the spirit of this holiday
[Music]
so that's all i got for today i'm hannah
and i want to know what you did for this
thanksgiving
let me know on instagram and if you'll
please excuse me i have some
holiday preparations to do now until
next time
[Music]
you